the Adam Carolla Show at the next live
podcast at the Irvine improv Thursday
October 5th is of Adam Carolla Show
experience 2.0 a four-day cruise for
crying out loud to check everything out
on Adam Carolla comm yes the ACE man
here in person good to see you
I just thought I think I'm leaving money
on the table I think I should cut off
one of my arms and make Adam Carolla
sausage out of it is that so
well I figured out a way to sir tea I'm
doing to me what the Indians did to the
Buffalo I'm using every part of me rich
hmm I'm having cruises and books and
podcasts and booze and the only thing
left is really just to start removing
flesh and making a kill by slaying
yourself yeah you're just parts of me I
don't need which part would that be why
it's a family show but let's just say
they're parts of me that are getting
larger and hanging lower and I feel like
women partake in this meaning they get a
breast job when things you know when
gravity takes its toll yes I feel the
same way about my scrotum and yours as
well not necessarily yours but I'm
saying ones ones ones generally speaking
on that front although you fall under
the umbrella of one now would that be
something you sell we don't give it away
you know you don't get to where I am
rich by giving away sad no you don't you
don't give away sack and have the kind
of empire that I have that's kind of a
stupid question is that the name of your
next book my next book I just I realized
will be everything reminds me of
something it's why I can't get through a
conversation because everything reminds
me of something in the middle of the
conversation it's a book that never ends
that's right or so are you normally a
cruise person though Adam do you'd like
if given a choice of vacation you would
no I I would I never would go on a
cruise Oh me and Jimmy went on a cruise
a million years ago to like Ensenada
like the cheapest like man
our planet before the man show Jimmy and
I decided to take the wives on just the
cheapest you know princess like $289 you
know three night you know to Ensenada
kind of thing so we did that it was not
a wonderful experience well I had this
way it's a weird thing when you're at
sea because the very first night we sat
down and they do the kind of festival
dinner seating you're sitting at the
table next to the guy in in defending
your life who got 13 days because he
invented all nudes remember those bars
by the airport yeah they just said nude
he put all nude that's the guy that's
like the guy you're sitting at the table
web right and so but I had a weird
realization so I said we're we're we're
at sea and the salads came and I said oh
could I have some balsamic vinegar and
they said we don't have that and I
remember being at sea and not having
balsamic this is a first world problem
but a problem nonetheless you're the
restaurant and there's no balsamic
vinegar you go don't worry i'll chug
some when i get home or i'll get my fix
when i get back to the pad but when
you're at seats are very vulnerable
feelings
yeah like well is there a helipad here
like where's the local Albertsons like
so that was a scary moment for me then
we did an Adam Carolla cruise with the
listeners about a year ago and it was
great you'd think it'd be insane being
trapped on a ship with a bunch of fans
but it was actually it was good fun well
because you brought all the balsamic
vinegar brought all the balsamic vinegar
and my a-game so it was it was great and
now we're doing it another one I don't
know I do I do have this reaction about
cruising and I remember my attorney Andy
said to me once and it was a real
indictment of me and my relationship
with my own family meaning my mother and
my father
uh-huh he said to me oh I'm gonna be out
of town that month or whatever and I
said what are you doing and he said I'm
going on a cruise with my mother and I
went oh
oh my god Oh brutal brutal what happened
how did you get forced into that she
have terminal cancer like what happened
and he's like I like my mom oh oh
brutal brutal and then it made me
realize oh no I have a horrible
relationship with my mom right and
that's why you saying I'm going on a
cruise with your mom sounds devastating
to me but in fact you enjoy your mom's
company well I mean I have a good
relationship with my mom but I wouldn't
I don't think want to go on a cruise
well now I don't think her with me I'd
be honest it's it's weird and there's a
little sexual connotation
you know if sexuality was powdered sugar
you you you would be like a cannoli and
I mean it's just a little dusting of
sexuality because it's a boat I don't
know when somebody says to me I'm going
to a Golden Corral with my mom I go good
for you I'm going on a boat Adam Carolla
here on the on the Rich Eisen show okay
so is your middle name is still Lakers
yes again you did not have a middle name
I did not have a middle and you were
filling out a form for driver's license
the Rif don't have with my mom it's this
sort of lays a fair approach to naming
you know started yeah it all started at
birth and the bloom was off the roads
that's right I get angry at these kids
with what is your middle Dalton Phineas
September have rel like hold on you have
nine middle names have zero yeah I hate
those kids but yes my middle name is
less you just decided one day at the DMV
to ride it in and that the goalie didn't
get went right past the goalie they
didn't catch it
yeah it California DMV system well the
goalies over there aren't Grant Fuhr
that's more unemployable methadone
whose glazed over like a doughnut just
stamping things you know what I mean
like you push a cat out in front of them
they'll just stamp and y'all next so
that's who you're dealing with
yeah Oh Adam Lakers Corolla yeah would
you have liked if I gave you a choice
now yeah if that space is still blank I
gave you a mulligan yeah from the sports
world Oh Adam
well obviously chew I mean obviously the
Patriots are fantastic but that would
draw the ire of like the bouncer from
the Pittsburgh area you know when you
whip out the ID well I mean if you go to
Boston Adam Lakers Corolla
I still think might ruffle a feather or
two you're right I rarely go to Boston
but I can tell you this as a Rams fan I
learn the difference between Boston fans
and all other sporting fans and that is
after the Rams lost in New Orleans and
2000 or 2001 yeah 2001 everyone else
like a bit other Super Bowls and when
your team wins especially your first
Super Bowl you celebrate the Bostonian
fans don't celebrate they find people
and Rams jerseys and verbally abuse them
so their version of celebration is
verbally abusing the team that lost not
celebrating their own victory yes I keep
telling that guy over there cuz he's a
Masshole yes enjoy now they know there's
something loathsome there so
self-loathing like they they hate
themselves so much they hate everything
so much that they can only express joy
in the form of hate for the other person
is that I it's it's a it's a kind of
weird sort of it's like me it's like
when people say to me Oh Adam you're so
smart I go I'm not everyone else is just
dumb which kind of de facto makes me
smart but I don't get to label myself
smart I get to label everyone else dumb
right and in a weird way maybe it even
feels more powerful to be the guy with
the 97 IQ
in the room of dullards you know I think
that's what the Pats guys do is that
does that sound about right to you yeah
I mean we take joy in the hate they take
join the hate but it's because of a self
but that's part of joy
well there is oh yeah we all hate
ourselves well they all hate themselves
no there is that part in sports like for
instance my six-year-old son who I am
now indoctrinating into the world of
certain sports teams but not pushing it
on him I'm a Michigan Wolverine guy
right he saw a promo for the Ohio State
Oklahoma game that's coming up this
weekend he goes dad we got a route for
Oklahoma Saturday right and I almost
started breaking down crying like that I
have instilled sports hate in this
beautiful cry to me is a great moment
but but I don't need to celebrate
Michigan's win by sticking it in ratty
mint I've just beaten it's a very little
I had a moment friend I had a
breakthrough with my son too which is a
sort of just a general human first world
wiring thing where my son and my
daughter both with me at my warehouse
you know where I do my podcast well this
was the other one where all the Paul
Newman race cars are and they were
having a bitter land dispute over who
owned the passenger seat of my jag like
one yelled shotgun but the other had
yelled shotgun earlier in the evening
and now a shotgun shotgun shotgun and a
certain point I announced you know
Natalya my daughter you're you're
getting the front seat and Sonny
you're in the back seat and Sonny had
this as a compromise why don't we both
sit in the back seat meaning why don't
we both be miserable that's not
acceptable is it I I don't know but it
made me realize that's a uniquely sort
of maybe a human American in first world
like I like again maybe maybe I should
just drop him off at Gillette Stadium
because like his thing was it's not
being in the backseat that makes me
miserable it's knowing that there's
somebody in the front seat that
three miserable so far both in the
backseat then we'll both be equally
miserable and then I'll be happy and
you'll see tomorrow night amidst the
celebration of raising the banner for
the Patriots it'll all be the
commissioners here let's flip the middle
finger at him
well there's 70,000 of those well well
the barstool got the stool presidente
apparently got 30,000 towels 30,000 is
the number well I thought he's created
that of a face of Roger Goodell with a
clown nose on it oh really now at the
door handing him out at the door to
fence the clown nose what did you know I
feel like in this day and age of telling
the President of the United States to
suck it I just feel like the clown nose
on the Commish is kind of to me ha say
you're a Rams fan yeah okay they won
once in your lifetime yeah I'm a jet fan
they won once in my lifetime but I was
an infant right if they win the Super
Bowl I don't care if it's a tie if we're
sticking it to the commissioner it's
gonna be a party there's no room there's
no room for flipping the middle thing
can I say this about Roger Goodell sure
it's his head fat or thin I feel like he
has both you know what I mean like Artie
Lange has a fat head Hank Azaria has a
thin head yes Roger Goodell has both so
what I don't know what it is I don't
know who has that you know yes if his
head is simultaneously chiseled and
sloppy like at the same time you don't
see that in the same guy as what I'm
saying
he's the Hank Lange or Artie's area of
sports authorities I would have speaking
of which speaking of the commissioner
I want to try and figure out a way that
we can get the replay [ __ ] on his desk
oh that would be and I want to take a
break and come back and try anyway I'll
talk about that maybe if we could get it
in the form of a towel yeah just remove
the whole zip-up leather outfit it's
probably a good thing
next off the top of my head
Carola is here we'll finish up the show
with him actually when we come back
[Music]
bring out the [ __ ] it feels sleepy I
guess you just have to wait come up now
won't you imagine that in an NFL stadium
when there's a conundrum on the field
and it needs to be replayed and Adam
Carolla you came up with an idea that
there is a [ __ ] in the stadium correct
they all have one assigned to them each
stadium has a [ __ ] assigned to it right
okay so the Jets and Giants playing the
same stadium so there would be 31
giimpse right and what would these games
do again well they make an unbiased call
because it the idea dawned on me when I
was watching all that replay stuff and
it was clear to us that he got his hands
and he made a football move by the way I
would define catching a football as a
football move I'm old-fashioned that way
when somebody catches the football they
then check the box football moves yes he
caught a football yes hey guy threw it
to him he was in a uniform and he caught
it yes football move but we see the
thing where he catches the ball he
starts to turn he takes one step he gets
blown up by the safety the ball goes
squirting out your team recovers you're
going nuts then they go back and they go
not enough to overturn what we already
call correct my feeling is is I don't
like that factor that taints it I want a
fresh set of [ __ ] eyeballs on this thing
and so it's fresh because the [ __ ] has
been in a box or in a trunk we think
there's many things we call it no the
deal with the [ __ ] is he doesn't know
the team he doesn't know the players he
doesn't know what city he said doesn't
know the date he doesn't know who's
president he doesn't know anything he's
a [ __ ] he comes out first thing he's
blinded by the Sun he's not seeing the
light of the Sun and weeks now does this
and he's flying it he's he's disoriented
and we run him he has a handler you know
sort of like Bevo coming out yeah like
like the Buffalo yes a couple of but
they're scantily clad but still the
cowboy hat flies off when they're
running with him there is some
showmanship to this absolutely the
crowds going nuts
they run him out there and they're
flogging him you know he has he has his
leash but they're also using it to beat
him as to bring him out of court between
the sunlight and being flogged that they
push him under the thing and he just
makes a declaration he doesn't know what
two teams are playing he doesn't he's
not in a fantasy league yes no nothing
riding on this at all it's like did he
catch it did he do it once he does it
now obviously if it goes against the
home team that's when they double down
on the beatings of the guy they run him
back into his pen now the fact that
there's no more hood by the way I don't
know if you're aware of this is now just
a tablet it's just they hang the tablet
out because they don't want the refs
running underneath the hood sometimes
the the apparatus is in the bowels of a
stadium Reilly closer to where the [ __ ]
would ramen ate from right right
now it's just a tablet is this change
anything in your mind no as long as we
do it right at the 50-yard line and
right in the middle and field we'll put
it up on the jumbotron and as long as
their handlers /ur the dominatrix is
there waiting you know for the beating
if he goes against the popular opinion
and we can run him back like the Buffalo
then no I don't think the tablet okay
I've got about two minutes left here
Adam how do i how would you suggest I
bring this up to the ultimate
authorities than the National Football
League I mean how do I unveil this idea
to make sure it works I mean you're a
corporate man again you've got your
podcast you've got your day crews and I
think you remind everybody it's a sport
but it's a business first like we're in
the entertainment business you know what
I'm saying sure and just like you've
read some of the endzone celebrations
and other licensing rules that are of
that nature you've done it not because
you're purist but because your business
people and you understand there's a lot
of stuff going on with the MMA
and pro wrestling and why they they get
it they get their entertainment and we
got to keep up with the Joneses and if
we're just gonna have some middle-aged
dude with salt and pepper in his hair
you know Donnell over to it that's the
last time you saw your grandfather stare
at a tablet exciting would you call that
it's exciting no we're in the
entertainment business and in an order
to entertain we need to innovate we need
to innovate to entertain you understand
and this is innovation it's the kind of
thing that yeah a couple of purists will
frown on a couple early but soon just
like all the other innovations and then
you do this when you do a moral
equivalency think remember a few years
ago no black quarterbacks in the league
okay now we have black quarterback is
this a good thing and they go well
course it's good you go well there you
go you see what I mean you take us sort
of you take a false moral equivalent and
you try it to it right and then no one
see you against black quarterbacks um
with ups really well then you're not
against everything you're in the gym
right now you know the game Adam Carolla
dot-com for tickets thanks for coming on
at him you're good thanks Reggie you got
it the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches